hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google so I did a dev
bites recently talking about
anticipation and overshoot principles
from cartoon animation that could be
applied to some user interfaces as well
we also talked about this in our google
i/o talk called a moving experience you
may want to check that out for more
information on some of these principles
but I wanted to go a little bit further
into these principles of anticipation
overshoot today in a different demo so
let's take a look so as I click on the
button you'll notice a couple of things
one is it reacts to my press itself and
then as I let go of the button then it
springs over to the other side of the
screen so press sort of skews over to
the left and then shoots over to the
right and then wobbles a bit to settle
down into place so that's the demo
pretty awesome let's take a look at the
code so first of all we want to figure
out how to actually draw something like
this you there is no skew property there
is no wobble and wiggle property on a
view so we need to do this manually by
altering the canvas of a view so you
don't typically over I draw and if you
do very important you have to call super
draw because we do things internally the
track flags and state that you should
not skip okay having said that it's okay
to override draw and in some cases you
have to in particular in this case I
want to change the way the view is
actually drawn so I need to alter the
canvas that it's drawn with so the way
you do that is by overriding draw and
then altering the canvas and passing
that up to the superclass so when there
is this skew value which is going to be
animated or change between 0 & 1 then
we're going to change the cannabis
itself we're going to translate around
here which is basically only set the
right look the the rights center around
which we're actually doing do the skew
then we're going to skew the object to
sort of give it this shifted to the
light right or the left
look and then we're going to call super
draw and just say okay now draw your
button now that I've completely mucked
with your canvas go ahead and draw
meanwhile here's how one of the
animations work so run press annum gets
called when we actually press down on
the button and that works by using an
object animator which is going to
animate this property called skew X on
this object so I've defined a property
setter called sets QX and I can use an
object animator to animate that
arbitrary property on my object and I'm
going to animate it between point 5 and
negative point five and i'm going to set
a particular duration for that thing and
so it's going to be awfully long as it
rears back and this is the anticipation
element of this animation is that it's
going to rear back before moving forward
you think you can think of this button
is one of those old cartoon characters
it's going to run forward but before
they do that they're going to rear back
so that it get all position and ready to
do it that's effectively what I wanted
the button to do here and then i'm going
to set interpolator so it starts very
fast I'm going to click on the button
it's going to quickly start into the
animation and then slow down as it gets
to the insert giving that tension feel
as it gets to its its extreme point and
then we start the animation if we look
at the motion handler so I handle touch
events directly here because I want to
know when I'm inside and outside the
button so that I can disable the
animation if they unclick when it's
outside all that stuff and I also wanted
to handle the the perform press
operation and I want to handle the up
animation so when they've actually
pressed then we perform our click
animation and the cliq animation is
going to animate across the screen and
then it's going to animate the skew to
the other side this is this is an
overshoot element where I want it to
stop suddenly but if it's an organic
element like this sort of skew II
squishy button that I've defined then
all of it can't stop at the same time
because that's very unnatural instead
you're going to stop the button and then
part of its going to carry on because
that's what gravity and inertia and
motion does to our bodies right so the
bottom of its going to stop and the top
is going to carry on and then it's going
to wiggle back and forth so it's going
to overshoot back to its original
starting location and then eventually
look like
normal button so if we take a look at
the click Adam here's where we actually
launched the animations so here we're
going to set up the the if we hadn't run
the full anticipation animation yet
we're going to hurry up and finish that
one up before we actually launched the
moving animation now we're going to move
the thing across the screen this is
going to animate translation X property
on the view from wherever it is on the
left or the right to the other side of
the screen we're going to set an
interpolator of a linear interpolator
this is interpolator that I defined
above this is an important point I would
never use linear interpolation on a
movement because it looks totally fake
instead people things in our real world
accelerate into motion and decelerate
out of it and that's a very natural
feeling motion for user interfaces as
well however in this particular case the
effects that I wanted was for the
anticipation to be the sort of
accelerating into this and then I want
the motion to start immediately when you
unpressed abut in' I want that button to
start immediately and move very quickly
across the screen and I want it to very
quickly stop on the other side of the
screen because that's where I wanted the
follow through motion of the button
actually overshooting where it was and
then wobbling back to the start so
interpolating linearly is totally
appropriate here because we're basically
accelerating into with the anticipation
and we're decelerating out of it with
the overshoot animation on the other
side of it so linear animation unusually
for a movement and then we wanted to
find the animation for the other side of
the screen so it's skewed over to the
left what we want is when it reaches the
right hand side of the screen we want it
to skew back over to the right but
overshoot and then we want it to wobble
back to where it was before so this is
the skew animation to go to the other
side and we're going to do a quick
decelerator so I wanted to very quickly
slow down from the speed that it had
from the linear motion linear
interpolator that had before in the
previous animation and then I want it to
wobble and the wobble is going to again
animate the skew property and it's going
to use this overshoot interpolator which
will end up at the final value but it'll
overshoot it first so that's exactly the
effect I wanted is we've overshot to the
right and now we want it to wobble back
past the stopping point and then
eventually end up at the stopping point
we use an animator set to do these
things sequentially so we're going to
play all the animations in sequence
we're going to move the button sku past
for the overshoot and then wobble back
to the starting position the normal
position for the button and then we're
going to play it and that is it thanks